anxiety is telling us that we need to
pay attention to ourselves and yet we
see it and we try to silence it even
more we think of anxiety as something
that we need to just run away from but
similar to pain it's a reality that
means you need to listen more to
yourself a lot of people approach pain
in that way too they think that if I'm
in pain you know I need to try to shut
those feelings down when in truth it's
the exact opposite it's your
self-consciousness of your internal
system begging you for attention
hopefully you know who you are at your
core you could feel that by connecting
to your heart but it's also something
that is in the field because you could
say that in the holographic field around
us there exists really a true version of
us so you could be picking up that
information as you're entangling with
your higher self that's coming through
intuition through subtle cues which a
lot of people wonder what's the
difference between then fear and
intuition if intuition can come in the
form of fear when we feel like we're out
of alignment with our higher self fear
in the mind is usually the opposite of
intuition something that feels like fear
because when you're in your heart you
feel out of alignment with something
you're dealing with externally could be
the intuitive cue you need